what's up everyone Matthew encina here
and in this video I'm gonna review the
work of Morris Caligari he's one of my
students from the style frames course
where I teach you guys how to create
dynamic frames in Photoshop that tell
amazing stories so this is part of a
project that he's working on it's called
port is based around a researcher in the
distant future after her planet's
resources have become scarce to combat
extinction this researcher has been
assigned to examine a new planet and
test if any areas are habitable quick
travel portals have been set between
bases throughout 50 percent of this
planet by previously failed excursions
unfortunately for the researchers who
agree to take this mission the portal
home will not activate due to
unforeseeable risks unless a usable soil
and water sample is found so that sounds
pretty cool port is this IP that Morris
is working on he posted this in the
slack Channel I loved it so much that I
wanted to give it my critique because
there were little things that I wanted
to adjust with the frames that he made I
have his frames opened up here in bridge
and I gotta say these frames are
beautiful let's start with his hero
image here I think this is pretty
awesome I like how simple this is you
have this nice silhouette of our
character here she's kind of outlined or
Rim lit with some of the glowing
elements on her suit and this rim light
that's on top of her head and Morris is
playing at my heartstrings right now
using Futura here that's one of my
favorite fonts of all time and we use
that on the main Future channel quite a
bit this is a great hero frame that can
be used as like the key image when he's
promoting this project next this is a
wide shot that he had painted it looks
like this is all photo comp together and
I'm assuming this is this inhabit
uninhabitable planet or at least the
planet that our character has traveled
to so he's given me a big wide shot
there's water here they need to see if
the the dirt is is viable in terms of
growing life here so this is a pretty
rad shot I mean there
little details here in the water here it
looks like just a little bit sloppy but
you know to be honest for a lot of these
concept frames as long as there's enough
information there and it sells the idea
you don't need much more so little
things like that yes it would be nice if
it was cleaned up but it's not 100%
necessary so this is a cool wide shot
you get a sense that this little
character here on the left bottom that
she's all alone because she's tiny in
this very very big world so this is a
nice way to represent that in this big
frame next were close-up on our
character and just like Morris had told
us she is checking the viability of the
soil here so she's exploring here on the
planet and this is a close-up shot of
her looking at the dirt sample so I
think the framing is all right here I
think it might have been more
interesting if we were actually a little
bit more in front of her where we the
hand was in the foreground much bigger
and we are looking at the reflection of
the sample in her helmet here in the
visor here so while I think this frame
is pretty cool I think it could have
been a bit more dynamic with the hand
much bigger in the foreground and the
character's head behind it so a little
tweak there and I think this frame would
be killer next we have this medium shot
it looks like this is a vehicle that the
character rides around the planet on I
love this shot it's a cool up shot where
it's very humid the character so our
camera angle is low around her knee
looking up and we get a sense that she
is the hero in this environment what I
like about this is the sense of depth
you get this nice foreground element and
a couple of layers of mountains going
back I think there are some little
tweaks with the contrast if I squint my
eyes I feel like the contrast needs a
little bit of work
I feel like this character can pop out a
little bit more with darker valleys and
the background can protrude back a bit
more with lighter values so I will be
tweaking that and I think that's it so
these are Morris's frames I think
they're quite beautiful I think he's
done an amazing job but I'd like to get
in and tweak some of his
based off of my personal preference so
I'm gonna start with this frame here
which I've done a little bit of work on
already
so this is where Morris was and after I
had done my tweaks this is it after so
what you'll see in this frame is I
increase the contrast overall I played
with the values and I adjusted the
layering of the elements so I'll break
this down one at a time so you can kind
of see what I did here so I'll turn all
of these off so first I was looking at
the background and I was trying to push
that's my dog chewy he's barking alright
so first I started with the background
and I wanted to push some of the
elements back so if I'm looking at some
of the background stuff I did I added a
few more layers of clouds just to get a
little bit more value change so I just
added this as a soft light in the
background then I added a little bit of
a haze this is just another soft light
that I painted so it lightens the values
in the background the more detail I used
the warm sky because I looked at what
Morris had done and I felt like
everything was just all blue and I
wanted to have a little bit more
contrast between the the hues so I
wanted to use a complementary color to
all of the Blues that he was using here
so I added a little bit of warm detail
here with this sunlight passing over our
character and in the background so you
could see what that looks like here it's
very subtle as you see these will all
add up then I started adding more
background haze trying to push that
background even further back and you can
see now the background now is this
extreme background here and then the mid
ground here with this mountain now
there's a lot more separation with the
tube then I wanted to enhance this warm
light so I just painted a very soft warm
sunlight here and then I wanted to start
increasing the foreground contrast so
I'm going to turn these three layers on
and you're gonna see I just added these
mostly as a soft light no actually these
are just curves I just was messing with
the curves and I masked out the areas
you could see the the layer masks right
here and I just adjusted the value so
that the I'm only messing with the
foreground adding a little bit of warmth
adding more contrast and then darkening
this spot here because it was a little
distracting for my eye
next I started adding some effects so
you'll see this in my folder here and
essentially I wanted to add this cool
low-lying fog just to give this shot a
little bit more atmosphere so I found
this cool image the stock image of some
fog let me show you guys there let me
isolate that all right let me open that
up so you guys can see what that looks
like so I found this cool image on a
stock site very cool so I painted some
of that in here having it come out of
the exhaust of the side of this vehicle
and then let it sit on the floor here
and I color corrected a little bit to be
more blue just to match the environments
around which you can see here just a
little bit of color correction and then
overall I started doing a couple of
things I added a vignette to this where
I'm just closing off and darkening the
edges here just so that the highest
point of contrast is on our character's
face right here so I'm closing up some
of the details on here so that we could
look at this character next I did a high
pass it's going to be hard to see this
but you could see it in the details here
of the vehicle let me just isolate this
high pass basically what a high pass
does if you go to filter go to other and
go to high pass what it will do is it
will look for all of the edges and
enhance them in Lightroom this is called
clarity so that's kind of what it's what
it's emulating but it's taking all the
edges and enhancing them so if I go
really close you can see what I'm
talking about here so this is with it
off and with it on you can see how it's
sharpening the details on the globe so
it's just taking all the edges and I'm
using this as an overlay to pump up all
of the edges then lastly I did some
curves just to do a final balance
because I wanted things not to go to
pure white into pure black I liked it
that things are a little bit on the
softer side so you can see I lifted the
blacks here and the curves and lowered
the lights here and then I use a
selective color to just tint the blacks
so I saluted the blacks and you see I've
adjusted the magenta and the yellow and
the black here just to give it a little
bit more of a cool style so if we look
at the overall finish of this
this was all of my work that I've done
to it on top of what Morris had some
more has had a great fantastic base what
I did is I just jumped in there played a
little bit with some of the color tones
and the contrast to make this frame pop
let me know in the comments if you like
this one better or if you liked Morris's
better before I messed with it next
let's go to his hero frame I really like
this thing right this is the hero frame
that is being used to showcase as the
key image for this IP this project and I
did some fun stuff with this so this one
I do have a speed design let me show you
what I ended up with so this one I added
dual colors you know I see this a lot in
sci-fi movies where they have a blue
light and a red light and I just wanted
to play with the tones just to get a
little bit more diversity of color in
the frame then I added all these light
leaks and a little bit of lens flares in
there and then I was playing with the
kerning and positioning of the letters P
ort for port so let's get into the speed
design so you can see from beginning to
end what that looked like alright so
first I started by raising the values up
and punching the contrast then I started
exploring making this frame a duotone
where we have a blue color on the left
side and then I was exploring some
magenta or some orange or some purple on
the right side just to make it a little
bit more interesting you can see how
swinging the hues a bit trying to see
what works best a lot of it looked muddy
if I started exploring and went on to a
stock site and started bringing in some
lens elements some colorful light leaks
and I started bringing them on top of
the frame and I started playing to see
if I could bring in these light elements
to see if it might break up the frame in
an interesting way and give us some
interesting lens artifacts so I have
this red one that I put in the top right
and I got these anamorphic lenses that I
had bleed in on the left and the right
side of the frame then I started playing
with the typography a little bit I kind
of bounced around just trying to
rebalance different parts of the frame
so I kerned outport I spread it out made
it bigger and then I started playing
with
values again and then I started playing
with the overall contrast and I looked
at it it was starting to feel a little
bit muddy so I had to go back in and you
know I started exploring with other
elements I wanted small particulates in
the frame just to make it feel a little
bit more realistic a little bit more
interesting so I was playing with these
small fire particulates that I found on
the Internet and I started dropping them
in on the right side of the frame just
to see if they could creep in
then I revisited the typography again my
wife said the type was too big so I made
it smaller turned it out and I added
more lens elements as you can see here
I'm just subtly painting them in and I
ended up using maybe about five six or
seven different layers of these lens
elements and I was just using them all a
little subtly and layering them on top
of each other just to make it feel a
little bit more dynamic as you can see
as I'm starting to get to the end the
frame started to look a lot more
interesting because I had a better
dynamic range of color things started
getting darker as they reach the edges
and I have all these interesting light
leaks and lens flares coming in so let
me know what you think if you like
Morris's frame better before or after I
started messing with it alright so I
wanted to answer this question that
Morris had he asks the story is pretty
involved so what I have only establishes
the look for the most part if I were to
pitch this as a short film music video
or whatever how should I focus my future
style frame efforts so when you're
pitching your ideas I think you want to
do a couple of things first when you're
making a couple of these frames focus on
the big steps if this was a two-hour
movie show me what every 20-minute block
is going to look like
start with the drama drop me right into
the conflict what's the challenge here
because that will get me excited right
away with these frames because it takes
a lot of time to render and produce
obviously you want to get the most bang
for your buck so show me the biggest
moments because that will help me piece
together what the five steps are in the
story arc other tools you could use you
could use mood boards which are just a
bunch of references that you pull from
different sources to help fill the gaps
of maybe
from parts of your story or if you're
painting the idea of what your world
looks like you could use mood boards you
could also use something called a sizzle
reel which is basically taking a bunch
of references that already exist cutting
them together it's kind of like a moving
mood board and it gives you a feeling a
moving feeling of what the final piece
might be about so that's another tool
you can use to pitch your idea so
hopefully those tips were helpful for
you Morris hopefully that answered your
question
if you guys have more questions about
how to pitch your ideas or how to make
frames let me know in the comments
section below if you want to learn more
about the art of creating beautiful
style frames consider taking my course
where I teach you my process of
designing dynamic images to tell
powerful stories I'll leave a link in
the description below and as always
don't forget to Like subscribe and
comment because it really helps us out
and don't forget to hit the bell icon so
that you never miss another episode like
this well thanks everyone thanks for
joining us with that out of the way it's
time to get back to work see you guys